[Music]
so this session today is about the
question of morality of the tribe and
universal ethics in should you be
impartial in some ways that might seem
the answer is obviously yes but if you
don't think what impartiality means if
you take it very seriously it means not
giving any special preference to your to
your family or your children your your
and your neighbors necessarily maybe not
even your species which is an issue we
may or may not get on to later so we've
got a great panel to talk about this to
my immediate right so it David Miller
he's professor of political theory at
Oxford and has been described we don't
know who by as one of the world's
leading political philosophers far right
Nathalie Cargill she's the founder and
executive director of effective giving
UK which is a nonprofit which helps
donors maximize the impact of their
donations she's also an associate tenant
barrister sergeants in chambers and has
worked with the UN Human Rights Council
and to my immediate left is Peter
Tatchell
well-known activist author co-founder of
the queer human rights group outraged
campaigns for human rights all over the
globe in all sorts of parts of the world
so we're very glad you arrived in one
piece today I think can we start with
you David we want the question really is
about are we to an extent justified it
right to think that morality has a kind
of a tribal element let's put it that
way
good thanks yeah that's the question and
the first thing I think to say is that
morality is a very complex thing it's
more like a department store than a
specialist boutique you could say and
many of the departments do have tribal
features in the sense that the duties
and obligations we have directed towards
those who are close to us our family
friends work colleagues people we
interact with on a daily basis
and of course we also have special
responsibilities to people we share
identities with people our faith
communities and I would argue our
compatriots last
description of how morality works in
practice doesn't so far justify it and
I'll come back to that but now you may
be asking but doesn't morality also have
universal features don't we also owes
things just to human beings regardless
of any special relationships we have to
them well we do have obligations of that
kind but I'm going to argue that to a
large extent those are negative in
character that's to say there are things
that we must not do to other human
beings no matter who they are we mustn't
kill them rape them exploit them torture
them deceive them those are all negative
injunctions don't do these things that's
very important that we have those
negative duties to people everywhere but
when it comes to positive duties things
were actively required to do for other
people then I think the scope is much
narrower now we do have a duty of rescue
that's to say a duty to save another
human being from death or serious injury
when we can do so little cost to
ourselves and that applies no matter who
the person is but unless we're
professional lifeguards were members of
mountain rescue teams that's something
really caught on to do on very rare
occasions and that's important so
positive obligations then are nearly all
directed to those we identify with
family friends and so on but how can we
justify that isn't it just prejudice to
discriminate in that way
shouldn't we be impartial help those who
need it most no matter who they are well
I think what that overlooks is the
emotional underpinning of morality some
reality isn't just rational calculation
it connects to feelings and sentiments
feelings like sympathy pride shame and
so on I think the philosopher saw that
most clearly was David Hume and Hume
thought if we didn't have those kind of
feelings we wouldn't have a moral sense
at all now of course
we can reflect on those feelings and to
some extent we can correct for them so a
parent for example might feel more love
for one child than another but she knows
that as a parent she has to treat them
fairly so she still has obligations to
her children not to just children at
large her children but she knows that
she mustn't play favorites the question
is how far can that correction of
instinctive feelings go can we really
feel the same kind of empathy for human
beings even if we share nothing with
them beyond their humanity we have no
shared history no cultural ties and so
on and why do we need to be impartial
because even this is the big if suppose
each community can look after its own
members the parent needn't feel guilty
about favoring her own children so long
as she knows and other parents are
looking after their children so we can
imagine a world in which all almost all
positive obligations would be internal
to communities and I think in some ways
that would be the best kind of a world
because it would allow different
cultures to develop in their own
distinctive ways without any kind of
outside interference however well
intentioned but of course that isn't our
well today and so our problem is how to
direct our emotional sympathies so that
we feel an obligation towards the people
who really need help and aren't getting
it from their own communities so we
can't avoid being tribal but we can
sometimes in to some extent stretch the
boundaries of the tribe outwards to
embrace more people thank you so much
David
I don't know if I'm doing the
interesting about that is it's what
you've done is a great service because
you've been immediately broken down any
suggestion this is a very
straightforward tribal or universalistic
debate and
you knowledge used to be argued for an
element of tribal attachment it forms of
a better word but also that doesn't
preclude certain universals that's
extremely interesting I'm Natalie
Cargill as somebody's involved with the
effective altruism movement I wouldn't
imagine your view to be exactly the same
so facts you could take your 4 minutes
to set your stall out thank you and I
think a useful distinction that you've
set out David is between moral
psychology and ethics so what do we
actually do in practice and what do we
think we should do and I would agree
that what we actually do in practice is
we behave and we feel model impulses
that are very tribal because we evolved
in tribes and that was something that
was really essential for our survival I
think whether we should accept that is a
different question and I don't think we
should there are two things that I would
say about that firstly when we look back
over human moral progress we could see
it as a sort of expanding circle of
individuals that we believe fall within
circle of compassion
so from originally perhaps just the
family to cities to States to nations to
different races and all of humanity and
of course hopefully not stopping there
and in terms of some of the most
shameful things that humans have done to
one another I think we can attribute
some of those great atrocities to a
failure to continue to expand our moral
circle so in the fifth century BC it was
perfectly acceptable for Greek
city-states that would be the limits of
your moral sphere of concern and Peter
Singer in his book the expanding circle
refers to a tombstone of a warrior and
on the same tombstone totally without
irony it says remember his name this
warrior killed seven men and speared
their bodies into seven parts he goes
down loved by all never having hurt a
man on the face of the earth and because
you're so completely outside the sphere
of concern and we've seen this failure
too
think beyond tribalism in many places in
terms of ongoing racism sexism
discrimination entire groups have been
marginalized for reasons that made sense
within the conventional tribal wisdom of
the time but which now looking back are
abhorrent and are deeply shameful and I
think it's very unlikely that we are the
generation now who is who has got it all
right and we can say okay well we've
we've settled on the obligations that we
owe to others and it's simply a matter
of taking care of our tribe I think the
second thing I'd like to stress is that
were in a really unusual situation
historically so for most of human
civilization nothing really happened
everybody was poor GDP didn't really
grow life was pretty miserable and the
sort of GDP looks like this and then you
get to the Industrial Revolution and it
takes off like this and we have an
enormous amount of wealth and
technological power and its enormous ly
unequally distributed and finally if we
rise above our tribal instincts and we
use reason and evidence we have enough
resources to solve problems that have
seemed intractable for example it would
take a fraction of a percent of the
income of the top 10% in the world to
provide everyone who's at risk of
malaria with insecticide-treated bed
nets or to provide all children with
parasitic diseases with treatment for
that disease that'll be a fraction of a
percent and on the flip side of that
there are problems that we're going to
have to work on in the next in the
upcoming decades that we will not make
progress on if we maintain this tribal
mentality the more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institutes of arson ideas at IAI TV
you